because yes they made me wonder like it
it made me appreciate
just how prepared are you for a disaster
right because it's just music huh vsauce
resource music right we were in the
penultimate episode of earth i think
right now you think
this is like penultimate episode kind of
fast wait hold on
we got a war going on we've got global
warming with the pandemic the
the earth shaking trying to rip itself
apart right
the mines were off by a few years you
know you know you know when you have
like the like when it's like the
disaster movie and you have the
beginning the acts one where you have
all of the indicators that the world is
ending
but nobody pays attention to it i
believe like 2020 has like literally
been that indicator irl quick take a
shot of the seismograph go crazy get
that on film
yeah cause like i remember like when the
lights went out
uh and i was walking around i was like
okay if this was like that's the title
of the movie when the lights went out
when the lights went out when we lost
power i was just like
you made me think what if this was like
actually just you know an a super super
serious earthquake and like the power
would be out for
a time when i didn't know when they
would be back on and well
[ __ ] batteries
which is just like i i kind of realized
how much foreshadowing of
i'm gonna call it foreshadowing right
because it's basically a chekhov's gun
at this point
of items i have collected thanks to
trash taste that would help me through a
disaster right so the first thing i
realized is i like
our house was the only house in our
streets with any lights on and that's
because i had my [ __ ] brick of a
power bank that i had accidentally
bought for the camping episode which uh
if you need a flat if you need a
flashback uh you can here's a here's
here's a thumbnail of the clip of me
talking about the brick that i bought by
accident for the camping episode but it
wasn't by accident but it was i didn't
know it wasn't by accident like the
script he foresaw what was gonna happen
the scriptwriters for trash taste is
just like on another level like like
they they foreshadowed this like two
seasons
is writing the dance line
so like i i remember the lights being
off and me thinking [ __ ] i do not have
any torches or any sources of power
wait a minute
and i remember i thought i'd never ever
actually be able to use it for the use
that it was intended for and luckily i
had just charged it like a week before
so like we just plugged we we could
literally just plug in our lamps and we
just lit up like our bedroom like it was
normally in your entire house yeah yeah
we could charge our phones and
everything but like beyond that i was
also thinking what if like what if this
was a natural apocalypse and we needed
to
uh we needed to survive for you know a
bit longer and i remember uh do we have
any like do we have like a good supply
of water or
supplies to emergency rations to get us
through the day and i was like wait a
minute i just bought an entire like me
and sydney both have an entire fridge
full of green tea that we bought as like
an aesthetic thing for our streams right
so if you've seen any of my streams or
any of my uh any of my uh on camera
shots there's there's a mini fridge that
i have and that's just full of green tea
that could last me
for a decent amount of time and
beyond that i also have a backup just
like an entire crate full of green tea
so i can like constantly refill this up
so unknowingly just from trying to make
something look aesthetic in my
background i'm able to like just survive
so much though yeah
i'm able to survive and not only that
i'm just like do we have any food to be
able to like last us i'm like
sydney's got like 10 months worth of box
shoes just lying about
so it's like thanks to boxing we also
have emergency rations as well
so i've got like an emergency kit yeah
so do i got like
uh quite a lot of water you got quite a
lot of water i've got that i've got like
that bottle of water that lasts like
four years or whatever it is
what yeah there's like emergency water
that japan makes where it's like water
that supposedly lasts emergency water
what do you mean it lasts four or five
years it's like been specifically made
so that it doesn't go off
yeah water can go off what i'm still
going to drink that [ __ ]
well yeah water can get stagnant almost
like bacteria and stuff but like they
have like special like it's like
acoustic it's called injury well i've
got like
i don't know like 10 liters of water or
something can bottled water go off yeah
yeah after a while like after like a
year i mean you could still drink it
like you can still drink it you'll be
fine you'll be fine yeah i've got like a
bunch of food i've got a wind-up torch
got uh some other [ __ ] wait so you
actually have an emergency kit yeah when
did you buy it
there's some on amazon yeah
one for a video yeah i don't know if i
don't use it i'll just uh whatever i
know you know i looked into it i was
like oh should i get one of those solar
panel
battery charging things turns out
they're like a lot of [ __ ] and
they're like barely working yeah yeah i
was like oh and there's someone like
just get a wind-up torch it's like way
better like just get the [ __ ] brick
[ __ ] battery pack they cost yeah
but like you've got to keep that thing
fully charged yeah if it's in my
cupboard for like 12 months it might
have half the charge
yeah half the charge could probably
still last you like six months yeah i'm
actually probably going to get like an
emergency pack now because i never
really thought about it before
before yesterday it
did humble me a bit just you know even
though even though just you know even
though you're fully prepared
even though i am i am prepared in many
ways thanks to thanks to trash taste and
uh trash taste lore and uh just being a
content creator you know
i did i didn't i didn't purposely
prepare for it but uh
sorry
but uh yeah i mean i just have a lot of
things lying in my house that is useful
for survival
watch those videos that are like what to
do if there's a nuke oh yeah you're like
all right
yeah you mean like the you mean like the
lie down with your mouth open
what do you think do you know that one
what's that one hold on tell me this
apparently i saw a video i don't know
how true it is but apparently it's like
it's like what what to do if a nuke uh
explodes like not not close enough where
it can like immediately kill you but
it's like if like the shock wave could
like possibly kill you and apparently i
don't know if this is true so please
take this with a grain of salt yeah but
it's like you have to supposedly lie
down with your like head facing
away from the blast and you have to have
your mouth open because if your mouth is
closed then the shock wave can puncture
your lungs
but if the mouth is open then it lets
the air escape from your mouth
supposedly that's like a trick
that people have just figured out again
mouth breathers rejoice we were talking
about breath
we were talking about useless skills
right i know that little useless
that is or it could come very useful
that is a piece of knowledge you see in
one life hack on a youtube show and then
you immediately forget about it
actually i wouldn't forget that that's
very rare yeah i remember and again i
don't know how true this is i've never
personally experienced anything like
that so i haven't tested it myself so if
i see a nuke going off i lie down on the
ground so say if it's coming out from
that window over there you would face
that one
yeah and yeah you'd like kind of have
your head down and you'd open your mouth
so that the shock wave can go through
your body
rather than it because if it's closed
then it gets closed off and it's still
going
right oh it's still gonna hurt but it
won't kill you is the thing i feel like
if a nuke's going off your life's pretty
[ __ ] anywhere well i mean if you're
close enough yeah yeah
obviously
i think you have like
i don't think anyone who was like oh
hold on
open your mouth guys
trust me like the next indiana jones he
does like he just [ __ ] the fridge and
he just just turns around with his mouth
he's like in the fridge and he's like oh
[ __ ]
i forgot
that only works the only reason the
fridge technically worked right because
it's a lead fridge right they don't have
lead fridges no they're not so i can
imagine much people jumping in their
fridges and it's like it's not gonna do
anything you just put yourself in a
coffin yeah basically you just made it
he's gonna cook yourself alive yeah
so i um
it was like uh they were saying so
you're 15 minutes when the nuke goes off
if you're not in the immediate danger
zone yeah yeah you're 15 minutes before
like the fallout reaches the ground
level yeah um so you need to get getting
daughters in 15 minutes and not leave
but you still might be dead from the
radiation yeah yeah of course but
obviously if you get any fallout on you
i think you die
yeah probably radiation sickness sounds
horrible
yeah yeah really really
chernobyl man that that that uh hbo
series is like rough well it wasn't just
that i think the one thing that really
horrified me was hearing about that
japanese guy who was like i think he was
like the most radioactive person who
ever lived oh right yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh it's like i think i've seen this i
saw a documentary on it was the one on
the
the fisherman was this that one i don't
think it was a fisherman he was working
for i believe a nuclear power plant or
something like that so um
for what i don't know the full story but
for whatever reason uh during a routine
maintenance thing with when he was
handling radioactive material um they
made a mistake uh due to like time
constraints and you know trying to get
this project done faster than usual so
they were pouring way more radiation
material into this tank than um than was
ever allowed by regulations right
um and you know obviously a chain
reaction happened something went wrong
and this guy who was literally standing
right next to the tank
um right next to the tank pouring in
this radioactive material he got hit by
the full blast of this chem
chemical reaction that was happening
right so he it's he was literally the
most radioactive person who has ever
been documented in history right
and um and it's like a [ __ ] horrific
story of like he actually survived it
initially right he survived it initially
and he they went to hospital and he on
the first day he looked so well
that the nurses were like ready to
discharge him the next day
that is until they like looked looked at
his like dna and his dna had been
obliterated like jesus like [ __ ]
obliterated right and i don't think like
anyone at that point realized the
gravity aside from like the doctors of
course realized the gravity of just like
what was in store for this guy because
like he got to the point where because
his cells could not make new cells right
um so it got to the point where the
doctors were trying to save him because
his family and himself wanted you know
to try everything they could but i feel
like it would have been less painful
just just to just let him pass away yeah
yeah because like it got to this point
where his body just started
deteriorating
um his skin would fall off
and would start bleeding and passing and
he'd like they could do nothing but just
bandage him up because there was no way
for like for his uh for his body to make
new cells and he's he basically just
deteriorated to death and it's like
you hear about the accounts of this and
it sounds like [ __ ] that's probably
the worst way it was
i was thinking of a different story uh
of like uh the guy who
was like living in hiroshima during
world war ii and then when the bomb
dropped right and he survived that one
yeah i mean he escaped with his family
out of hiroshima
to nagasaki
and then the second bomb dropped and he
survived that one as well
i thought i thought you were talking
about that story oh no no yeah i think i
think he must have been pretty [ __ ]
radioactive after that apparently i
don't know if this is true but i
remember hearing that there's more it
was not just him there's a few other
people as well but they they reckon that
uh maybe a hundred or so people have had
the same idea yeah yeah yeah
but they just don't know who they are
right yeah um but i mean that is
crazy yeah really crazy yeah yeah
definitely yeah
just like just like thinking of thinking
about it so there's a youtuber i can't
remember his name he talks about a lot
of these um uh radiation uh stories and
and uh mistakes and stuff i cover his
name he's um he does the science videos
as well [ __ ] camera's name they're
really really good right and uh is there
some other horrible stories about like
people doing experiments that went wrong
there was that other story i think i
know which you should be talking about
there was he did
amazing hair yeah did he make that video
on the guy who like stuck his head in
the hadron collider
yeah so yeah yeah and he got like shot
it wasn't
collider but it was i think a similar
thing yeah he got shot by an atom yeah
in the head and like penetrated his
brain and he
survived but like but yeah and then
there was some some like mix-up where
they thought he was alive he's like
amazing hair he's got like a lions man
not the guy who got shot the guy makes
the youtube videos
like this is this
yeah is this some new kind of like
therapy to give you like amazing hair
just kidding
are you experiencing hair loss boom
shot you've definitely seen this
thumbnail it's called the demon core you
seen this one
[Music]
it was just like nuclear act nuclear
active called it's always new clearly
yeah of course it was i can't remember
exactly what it was watch the video it's
really good and yeah just time about the
story and there's really really strange
sometimes you just think like why just
just leave it just don't just what
happened with the guy who got shot by a
dad i think he survived
he survived but then he
unsurprisingly developed these like
really weird uh like brain traumas and
uh like he i think he survived he
definitely yeah he survived he survived
for a while i believe but like he lost
all of his hair and then he uh yeah he
just had all these like weird brain
complications that the doctor was like i
don't know what the [ __ ] to do with this
yeah he's currently 79 years old and
living
79 years old and living okay
what a what a [ __ ] badass title got
shot by an atom yeah so we know that 100
of the time as we know you when you put
a head in uh
in a hadron collider you survive yeah we
have 100
survival rates
oh i'll [ __ ] stick my head in there
like tomorrow jump in the hadron
collider real quick there's been other
cases as well people get the um
uh
what's the thing that powers x-rays uh i
think there's like a
something i was one one i don't know if
it was actually exactly there's a
medical device yeah and some people
broke into an abandoned hospital right
like stole this thing right and they
just thought it was some kind of like
cool glowing thing yeah yeah turns out
that cool glowing thing was like
radioactive like uranium or something um
yeah i could be mixing up two stories
together here it's on his channel as
well really weird and now they're the
teenage mutant
whole i think it might be a different
story actually but yeah like the whole
village they were like everyone come
check out the glowing stones oh no no no
joke and people were all touching it and
playing with it
and like like a whole like like uh
family and a few other people died
because they were just touching and
playing with the stone [ __ ] you now let
me pee all right don't ever touch
glowing stones kids
if it's glowing that's probably a bad
sign that a chemical reaction is
happening there that shouldn't that you
shouldn't be holding right cursed glow
sticks cursed glow sticks making us
think that things that glow are so cool
god damn it